اذا اصبح لك سجنان السجان هو النظام الذي
يقمعك ويعذبك والسجان الاخر اشد وطئتنا
اشد
كيف كانت المعامله في الداخل مقاطعه تامه
مقاطعه تامه يعني
عدم
التعاطي معه لسنوات تصور هذا الموضوع بصير
لسنوات
معزول مكروه كم سنه
هو ضل 14 سنه بس مو كله بهذا المعجى ايوه
تنقل يعني خففت عليه الامور شوي انه راح
على سجن سيدنايا فتره بعد ما نقلوه من
تدمر وبعدين راح على سجن مدني سجن
تابع للشرطه المدنيه طيب والمقاطعه كانت
عمليا لا صباح الخير ولا مساء الخير حتى
الى هذا الكلام ولا كلام يعني بالفترات
الاخيره يعني خفت قليلا من خلال
بعض الناس اللي كانوا دارسين بفرنسا يعني
صار في معرفه نسيم ومجموعه من الاطباء
شخصيه اساسيه ايضا
وقت اللي عرف انه هذا وبعدين صار وبعدين
خفت الامور فتحت قبل انتقاله من سجن تدمر
لسجن صيدنايا
بفتره يعني قد يعني
تنقاس بالسنوات
قبل ما ينتقل على
بالسنه خفت شوي الامور وبعدين صارت شويه
طبيعيه عاديه نظل بعض المتزمتين اخذين
موقف يعني ما بتعاطوا معه يعني
في حاله من القوقعه
لكي
تنقذوا انفسكم او نسيكم يا قوقعه بالحقيقه
اجباريه اجباريه يعني المفروض من الخارج
يعني مفروضه من الخارج يعني بس فقط تتلقى
ولا ترسل ابدا ابدا يعني
بيروحوا عم بيجوا عم بيعيشوا حياتهم
العاديه داخل السجن يعني مثل عادي وعم
بيتعاقبوا وعم بيتعذبوا وعم كل المسائل
هذا وعم بشارك فيها يعني